عوده تقول الشباكتي في السودان بعد
انتهائه هدنه العيد وتصريحات لنجل ترامب
تثير غضب السودانيين وجدل حول مكافات
الرئيس التنفيذي لجوجل هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد ساعات قليله على نهايه هدنه العيد
عادت الاشتباكات لتتجدد في السودان بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع حيث سمع ذوي
انفجارات في محيطه مطار الخرطوم وشهدت
اعمده الدهان تتصاعد من المطار الذي لا
يزال متوقفا عن العمل منذ عشره اياما
وبخصوص الحديث حول استمرار وقف اطلاق
النار قال المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع فارس النور قال ان هدنه
جديده ستبدا خلال ساعات لافتا الى ان قوته
ستحقق اهدافها سواء بالعمل العسكري او
بالتفاوض فيما لم يعلق الجيش حتى الان على
الامر
في خبر يخص السودان ايضا لكن من الولايات
المتحده اثار نجل الرئيس الامريكي سبق
دونالد ترامب غضب السودانيين بعد ان وصف
السودان بعباره البلد القذر دون ترامب
جونيور انتقد في تغريده على تويتر طريقه
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في اجراء
موظفيها سفاره الامريكيه قائلا ان بايدن
ترك سته عشر الف امريكي فيما وصفه بالبلد
الفقير القذر الذي مزقته الحرب وان قدره
بايدن اقتصرت على سحب طاقم السفاره فقط
مغردون السودانيون سنتارو هذا التعليق
معتبرين وصفه السوداني بتلك العباره
بالامر المهين وطلب البعض منهم بحذف هذه
التغريده وبتقديم اعتذار رسمي
في وقت صرحت شركه جوجل نحو 12 الف موظفا
ضمن خطط واسعه لتقليص عدد موظفيها بحجه
تقليل النفقات تقاضى مديرها التنفيذي
نحو 226 مليون دولار خلال العام الفائت
كرواتب ومكافات وفقا لبيانات الشركه الام
الفابيت ذلك المبلغ الكبير اثار الكثير من
الجدل الذي قدرات البيتشايا السنوي بمبلغ
مليوني دولار لكن الفابيت منحته 218 مليون
دولار فوق راتبه على شكل مكافات اسهم من
الشركه خلال 2022 كما تلقى مبلغ 6 ملايين
دولار خلال العام نفسه خصصت للحمايه
الشخصيه بحسب الشبكه
بعد اقل من اسبوع على البدء بتطبيق قرار
الغاء العلامه الزرقاء لكل من لم يدفع
رسوم الاشتراك يبدو ان ايلون ماسك المالك
الجديد لتويتر بدا يتراجع عن قراره
باعادته علامه التوثيق لكل حساب يزيد عدد
متابعيه على المليون متابع تويتر بدات
بهذه الخطوه بعد كل من الكاتب الامريكي
ستيف كينج ولاعب كره السله الامريكي لبرج
جيمس والممثل الكندي ويليام الشاتنر ثم
تزايدت عمليه اعاده علامات التوثيق
الزرقاء المجانيه بشكل كبير وسبق ان اظهرت
بيانات عامه ان اقل من 500 فقط من اصل 400
الف حساب مواثق وافقوا على دفع رسوم جديده
لتويتر كما ان عددا من المستخدمين
الغشتراكهم نهائيا
ونختم من القاره العجوز حيث الوكاله
الاوروبيه للبيئه في تقرير لها قالت ان
تلوث الهوايه تسبب باكثر من 1200 حاله
وفاه مبكر سنويا لاشخاص دون سن ثمانيه عشر
في اوروبا الوكاله اضافت ان العديد من
الملوثات الرئيسيه في الجو لا تزال
مستوياتها اعلى من توصيه منظمه الصحه
العالميه لاسيما وسط اوروبا وفي شرقها
كذلك وفي تقرير اخر كشفت الوكاله
الاوروبيه ان ما لا يقل عن 238 الف شخص
عام 2020 توفوا مبكرا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفي تركيا والنرويج وسويسرا بسبب تلوث
الاجواء واوسط باهميه الحفاظ على الهواء
النقي بالقرب من المدارس ورياض الاطفال
ووسائل النقل المشتركه وغيرها من المنشات